here's one Up Tempo joint
[Music]
what you thinking love it this is it
film one all right let me see there's a
pad
over here too yeah
feeling beautiful feeling Fierce Rising
above yeah yeah definitely to the top
respects
lyrics just kind of come to us we just
say whatever comes to our mind like
we like feel our songs we're talking
feeling that that energy that Vibe you
know empowerment and just roll it up in
a ball and put it inside so we can make
a hit let's do it let's head to the top
respect
let's do it let's get ready to rumble
I'm ready ready you can nail it nail it
how's the 11.
come on Darcy big thing I'm On Top hair
done nails did I can't stop I'm on top I
got a attitude for this yeah catch up
yeah it's okay we'll do another one no
worries we both have our secret sauce I
got that silver swag first you got that
rasp that rasp that's right yeah it's
like voices you never heard before
unique
ready bring it bring it stay safe
one two three I'm on top hit another
okay
I'm On Top hairs done nails did I can't
stop but she said hairs hairs done hair
done oh she did say hair done
I said hairs
as performers I mean they're not the
greatest of singers they do just enough
to get by what they do that's not the
thing that they profess to be but that's
what technology is today hello everyone
I'm On Top heads on nails dead
what I got no come on
top heads on nails dude I can't stop
back respect that's it I can't I have
never seen anything like this in order
to pull this off
it's going to take an act of God but you
can't tell them that they can't do
something and they're Fearless
[Music]
thank you